i saw the movie too it was amazing i
thought you guys were gonna like uh go a
little less hard since y'all were
getting a little bit older you know but
when i saw johnny knoxville get [ __ ]
by that bull i was like these guys are
crazy
was it was is there like are you guys
planning on like a jackass next
generation kind of thing i mean i guess
that's kind of what this this uh last
movie because i know zac ass and i know
chad tepper oh yeah they uh i mean yeah
they brought in zach they brought in
poopy they brought in a bunch of new
guys to kind of uh
freshen it up a little bit yeah you know
i don't know what like celebrities mgk i
saw that yeah
i don't know but i always felt i always
felt like there should be like a jackass
next generation because like jackass
can't just end it never will and like
i mean
i don't know i mean unless that's what
you guys have decided on but i'll tell
you this when i found out that after 10
years knoxville wanted to make another
movie like i thought
man like
after every now we're so old that's a
potential problem
and like after everything that we've
survived like we've come this far and
like now like it just takes one
[ __ ] thing to go wrong and then the
whole
legacy of it
so when you say like the jackass the
next generation
you got younger kids i just worry about
like taking risks on and it's
ironic that i should be saying that you
know but uh no but it's it's respectable
because i do see where we're from
you know and and i mean the the
particularly ironic thing is that i'll
be taking plenty more risks just you
know doing my own thing
but uh you're putting out your own album
yeah putting on my own album and you
know like
such a weird thing with jackass when uh
you know like putting putting other
people in harm's way
yeah it's a tough one i mean some of the
stuff you have coming up is
some of the gnarlies i've ever heard in
my entire life so that'll be interesting
i'm excited to see that
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]